welcome back to curious archive
this video is the finale of my two-part
series on the biology of the video game
subnautica in these alien seas
breathtaking landscapes enormous
predators and unexpected mysteries are
still waiting to be discovered
and just like how life in earth's oceans
gets stranger the deeper you dive the
depths of planet 4546b are far more
extreme than what's on the surface
they're also highly dangerous and i can
confidently say that this ranks among
the scariest experiences i've had while
doing field work for the archive
but i'm determined to uncover the
secrets of this ocean
so ride with me and my deep sea
submersible as we conclude this
expedition into the unknown
to the north beyond the edge of the
grassy plateaus huge mushroom trees grow
in abundance
despite their name and appearance
mushroom trees are actually a
particularly long-lived species of coral
in the shade of these ancient giants a
new classification of life is swimming
these are jelly rays an ethereal ray
species with highly translucent bodies
in earth's oceans translucent life forms
are quite common in the lower light
depths the jelly rays are therefore a
sign we're getting closer to the deeper
and more fantastical regions of 4546b
beyond the safety of the mushroom forest
the twilight of the bulb zone awaits
here luminescent bulb bushes dominate
the landscape and have evolved to grow
in this rocky sandy environment thanks
to a highly advanced system of roots
and along the seafloor raging volcanic
geysers launch boiling liquid and chunks
of molten rock into the surrounding
water the extreme heat from these
geysers charboils any fish that swims
too close
an ominous light flickers in the merc
the source is an ampoiel a huge
serpentine predator covered with glowing
prongs that produce zaps of electricity
these aggressive creatures use electric
discharges to intimidate other life
forms and kill their prey with a single
deadly shock such living batteries might
seem biologically inexplicable but the
curious electric eel on earth might help
demonstrate how an organic creature
could produce an electric field
electric eels use disc shaped cells
packed into specialized organs to
generate their electric currents as
incredible as that might sound
so it's possible that the ampule's
prongs contain similar cells although
the bioelectricity of an ampoule is far
more extreme
a series of screeches announces the
approach of a legion of bone sharks
highly aggressive in territorial
carnivores it's unlucky to encounter so
many at once their thickly armored
exoskeletons which give them their names
are adapted not just to deter larger
predators but also other bone sharks the
distinctive segmentation of these
exoskeletons suggests bone sharks might
share a common ancestor with the sand
sharks we glimpsed on our last outing if
so it's a fearsome family tree
while returning to the shallows to
prepare for the next leg of my journey i
spot a new type of colorful fish
something about the way it looks is
truly hypnotic and i want to swim closer
and then it bites my nose
that is a mesmer a sneaky little
creature that looks harmless while its
four fins are folded up but unfurled can
create hypnotic patterns that have
evolved to distract prey while it goes
in for the kill
thankfully it seems i'm a bit too big to
be swallowed up but this is one fish to
avoid
with supplies replenished it's time to
venture further into the unknown under
the sea floor networks of caves lead
deeper into the uncharted interior of
planet four 4546b
some of these caves are massive and
contain entire ecosystems of their own
and the jelly shroom cave is one of the
most miraculous
here among the stalagmites grow jelly
shrooms massive highly luminescent flora
which might be distantly related to the
tiny acid mushrooms of the shallows
in the purple light of the jelly shrooms
shine the biters small carnivores that
stock these caves for small prey
the antenna on their forehead seems to
resemble the deep sea angler fish's lure
at first glance but the biter's antenna
actually serves an entirely different
purpose
it contains olfactory organs that help
it detect bodily fluids in the water
in other words the biter can smell its
prey anywhere in the cavern
unless of course the biter becomes prey
itself
winding through the cave is an
unsettlingly lengthy crab snake the apex
predator of this environment what makes
this predator so deadly is not just its
size but its ability to hide in plain
sight the crab snake has a symbiotic
relationship with the local jellyshrooms
using their hollow interior as the
perfect layer from which to ambush prey
in behavior and appearance the crab
snake somewhat resembles earth's bobbit
worm an unattractive predator that also
ambushes its prey
in the jellyshroom caves one needs to
keep an eye out
elsewhere on the seafloor another
shadowy cavern beckons
after many hours navigating the cave
system i surface in a cave that
strangely seems lit by daylight
i realize i've stumbled upon something
extremely rare for planet 4546b
dry land
this tiny island is the peak of an
undersea mountain connected to an
aquatic cave system and it's one of the
few places on the planet you can
encounter terrestrial life
scuttling along the beach are cave
crawlers as their name implies these
crab-like creatures have evolved to
crawl along the sides of cave walls
which is likely why they were able to
adapt to this fleeting land mass
relatively quickly
analysis of their biology suggests they
possess a gas exchange membrane to
breathe air instead of fully functional
terrestrial lungs
soaring overhead is a life form that has
spent much more time adapting to life
above the waves this is a sky ray an
avian creature that has remarkably
evolved powered flight
although its wings give it some
resemblance to aquatic ray species
analysis shows no particular genetic
link instead the sky ray appears to have
split off from the common evolutionary
tree much earlier than most other
species on the planet perhaps at a time
when dry land was more prevalent
in any case it seems we've now seen all
this island has to offer
[Music]
or maybe not on one end of the island is
a tremendous artificial spire this
mysterious monolith appears to be the
work of advanced extraterrestrials who
much like myself came to this planet
from afar
but did they come to study the life here
like i did or were their intentions more
sinister
in any case it seems this planet's
greatest secret is still waiting to be
uncovered
to the south the seafloor plunges lower
than ever before
we have come upon the grand reef here
orb like blue plants called anchor pods
risk floating off due to their
gas-filled membrane only staying in
place due to their net like root system
and nearby stomp a herd of sea treader
leviathans
these vast herbivores roamed the depths
in search of plants on which to graze
the thunderous nature of their rhythmic
steps is truly something to
experience perhaps the most curious
thing about these creatures is the fact
they have three legs something almost
never glimpsed in nature
analysis suggests their front leg is
actually an elongated snout used to
siphon plant material from the sea floor
and to maintain balance as alien as this
might seem there are some species of
earth tripod fish with elongated fins
they used to similarly stand on the sea
floor
right now it appears the sea treader
leviathans are migrating so it's best
not to disturb them
beneath the grand reef caverns take us
further into the abyss here the
intimidating crab squid waits to butcher
prey with its ten limbs
swim close to one and they'll unleash a
mysterious bioelectric discharge which
has the properties of an electromagnetic
pulse
while they appear to have massive brains
analysis suggests the large organ within
their translucent sac is actually their
stomach which the crab squid fill with
their bioluminescent prey
as a result they seem attracted to light
sources convincing me to make a hasty
exit from my submarine this turns out to
be a good call as it drags my sub into
the depths
if there are other creatures like the
crab squid on the prowl down here i'm
going to need something a little larger
for the next perilous leg of the journey
i'll be piloting a cyclops submarine a
vehicle that should be able to withstand
the crushing depths of the abyss
below the deep grand reef awaits a
surreal environment of eerie green fog
this is the lost river a region covered
in alkaline brine pools which give the
illusion of an underwater stream brine
pools also exist in earth's oceans and
are extremely toxic due to their high
salinity best not to get too close
above these pools drift the haunting
ghost rays
relatives of the jelly raised from the
mushroom forest in these extreme depths
the ghost rays have become almost
completely transparent to the point
where you can see the red of their
internal organs
elsewhere in the lost river blood
crawlers the spindly relatives of the
cave crawlers stride above the brine on
stilt-like legs rather unsettling forms
of life
in the central chamber something truly
horrifying is waiting this ancient
fossil belongs to a colossus far larger
than any that currently swims through
the seas
indeed it's so massive that its rib cage
has become part of the lost river's
landscape
we should count ourselves lucky this
unknown genus seems to have gone extinct
long ago
yet still alive are the river prowlers
these aggressive transparent predators
haunt the gravesite of the leviathan
like vengeful ghosts
even more frightening their forehead
tendrils can lash out when attacking
allowing them to pull in prey
not the sort of creature you'd like to
encounter in the dark
but there is a strange beauty to certain
regions of the lost river in a cove
under the central chamber the brine
becomes a harmless blue and ghost rays
flock around a massive central tree this
tree appears to be an ancient nesting
round as it is grown around a giant
bioluminescent egg while the egg itself
is beautiful whatever hatches out of an
egg that size might not be
to find the adult form of the huge
creature that hatches from this egg we
must venture into the nightmarish
darkness of the dead zone
here at the edge of the habitable region
for most fauna we've found our giants or
they've found us
these aggressive monsters are ghost
leviathans and they're a major threat to
this expedition analysis of their jaws
suggests they feed on microscopic life
forms that help them reach their massive
sizes although they seem fully capable
of feeding on something larger time to
head back the way we came
the mystery of the giant egg has been
solved but that's not the only strange
thing in the lost river these ruins of a
massive alien structure resemble the one
on the island the structure is guarded
by these life-forms the warpers who
possess a mind-bending ability at will
they can somehow fold space-time and
vanish into portals this is not the
ability of a natural life form it seems
we are dealing with an artificial
creation
searching for answers i enter the ruined
building
here we can see the unfinished
artificial body of a warper they did not
evolve in our creation of the
extraterrestrials
but for what purpose
translating a digital message it seems
these alien architects came to 4546b
many years ago searching for a cure for
a disease and the warpers are their
artificial quarantine enforcers
given the lack of any living architects
on 4546b
it appears that they were unsuccessful
on a table in a nearby lab they've left
behind an egg of a curious creature
after returning to the surface to
recharge my submarine i hatch the egg
and this delightful life form emerges
this is a cuttlefish a friendly rotund
little creature that displays high
levels of intelligence and curiosity
i've also found it's quite a fan of
treats
analysis suggests it's possible this
creature has been imported from another
world or even genetically altered to be
extra friendly it's possible the
architect aliens kept them as pets just
like we do with dogs
it's tempting to stay longer with the
cuttlefish in the shallows yet i can't
help but feel that in the abyss there
are more mysteries i've yet to solve
beneath the lost river the landscape
blazes with the fiery glow of molten
rock we've reached the lava zone the
deepest environment of them all
here incredible heat resistant forms of
life have evolved like the crimson ray a
ray species that have developed a molten
coloring to help it blend in with the
lava and the magmarang a relative of the
boomerang with a beautiful glowing tail
fin
another remarkable form of life is the
lava larva a grub-like creature that
feeds off geothermal and electrical
energy i first learned this fact when i
found one stuck to the windshield of my
cyclops draining its energy while this
behavior is somewhat annoying the energy
conversion capabilities of this creature
are truly remarkable
on the molten floor is something highly
alarming these skeletons belong to
reaper leviathans like the one we
encountered in our last voyage it seems
that somewhere in the lava zone is a
predator so large it can drag reaper
leviathans into the depths
this doesn't bode well
basking in the red glow of the molten
rock are lava lizards these predators
are too small to be our culprits but
they're nonetheless quite deadly for
defense they are able to cover their
bodies with hardened lava-like natural
armor
while such a behavior is far more
extreme than anything on earth scaly
foot snails which i've discussed on this
channel before can survive in volcanic
vents by incorporating iron scales into
their body like medieval armor however
lava lizard biology takes this to a new
level
at the end of the lava zone lurks a
massive chamber the loudest roar we've
encountered on our voyage shakes the
cavern
[Music]
we found our reaper leviathan slayer
this is a sea dragon leviathan the
largest predator in subnautica
possessing both arms and tentacles these
creatures exceed 350 feet or 112 meters
in length sea dragons get their name
from their ability to consume molten
materials and expel them at their
adversaries like their breathing fire i
can only hope this absurdly deadly life
form doesn't notice me
no such luck
a huge blow from the leviathan rocks the
cyclops submarine as a result there
appears to be a minor leak
out of options i have to abandon ship
luckily i have one last hope in the
prawn suit a deep sea mechanical walker
that should make an ideal escape pod
ejecting from the cyclops it's a bit of
a drop to the bottom
but it appears my plan has worked as the
sea dragon leviathan thinks its foe has
been vanquished
here at the end of our journey lies a
final mysterious building with some
difficulty i pilot the prawn suit over
to it inside locked in a containment
facility the largest creature of
subnautica is waiting
this is a sea emperor leviathan and
although it appears to be a relative of
the sea dragon it is in no way hostile
like real world baleen whales the
largest creatures on earth its diet
consists solely of microorganisms
while the sea emperor leviathan is so
large i am unable to get a proper scan
of it it seems that it can somehow
manipulate neurons to communicate
telepathically as it told me of its
plight the sea emperor was entombed here
by the alien architects in the hope it
could provide a cure for their disease
which i believe is in strict violation
of the intergalactic code of biological
ethics
at the request of this intelligent
creature i agree to take its hatchlings
back to the surface with me
watching the first moments of baby sea
emperor's lives is a truly wondrous
experience even after all the biological
marvels i've glimpsed thus far
[Music]
sadly the sea emperor is at the end of
its lifespan and informs me that it
won't be coming with us
at the very least i'm happy i can help
their babies live on in freedom it is a
bittersweet conclusion to a long and
winding journey
with the sea emperor babies returning to
their natural habitat our study of this
region of subnautica is at its end there
are other worlds waiting for us and the
time has now come to return to the stars
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
entry please lend your support and like
subscribe and hit the notification icon
to stay up to date on all things curious
see you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
you